Here we are in our Editor
and I've got the framework of a basic application.
And this is actually the framework I've been using for
the homeworks and stuff that I've been doing.
I've been using this notion of templates,
which is not something I'm going to explain thoroughly in this class.
But instead of doing string substitutions for big wads of HTML,
we can keep our HTML in separate files that look like HTML
and that have just little escapes for variables.
I'll be using that in this example,
and you're free to use them on the homeworks yourself
if you're tired of doing string substitutions
for generating large chunks of text.
And also--this kind of little framework, we can provide if you'd like to use that.
So all I've done is--
You may recognize this as a standard Google App Engine app.
I added a class, called Handler,
which this inherits from the webapp2 handler,
which is what you normally use.
And I've just added a couple of convenience functions.
I made a function called "write" which
just calls: response.out.right
so I don't have to type that all the time.
I made a function called render_str,
which takes a template name
and it returns a string of that rendered template.
And then I made another function called render,
which instead of returning just the string,
it calls "write" on it.
And I've got a Main Handler down here--MainPage--
which is mapped to from 'SLASH'
and all this does is it writes this string, ("asciichan!"), to the browser.
So let's go ahead and switch to the browser, real quick,
and make sure this is working.
Here we are, in our browser.
We're printing: asciichan! Okay, all is well.